[Musica]
buonasera a tutti
allora il viaggio di cui vi parlo questa
sera un viaggio che è un racconto che
secondo me molti di voi già conoscono
quelli più giovani probabilmente l'hanno
visto in una puntata dei simpsons dove
bart si ammala e omer viene ridotto a un
microbo entra nell'organismo di bart e
cerca di guarirlo quelli che sono
diversa mente giovani come me potrebbero
averlo visto in questo film di
fantascienza degli anni settanta cosa
succede tra che il web viene attaccata
dagli anticorpi in una scena famosissima
perché si trova all'interno di un corpo
umano all'interno di un paziente che ha
avuto uno stroke dello stroke si
verifica quando un vaso cerebrale
fabbricato per portare sangue al
cervello viene chiuso da un coagulo il
sangue non passa più il cervello morirà
il paziente probabilmente morirà
la storia dirà che wentz comincia in un
laboratorio segreto sotto il deserto del
nevada la storia vera la storia che ha
reso questa fantasia una realtà nel xxi
secolo comincia invece a lisbona circa
un secolo fa vedete una città di mare e
vedete su questo tram che porta
all'ospedale principale la città c'è il
nome moniz monizza era il titolare della
cattedra di neurochirurgia verso il 1905
1910 ed era un chirurgo famosissimo era
già famoso aveva già ricevuto il premio
nobel perché aveva proposto un
intervento che per i tender ha
assolutamente rivoluzionario
dell'intervento si chiamava lobotomia
frontale per vento semplicissimo c'era
il problema dei pazzi furiosi cioè
pazienti psichiatrici che erano
incontenibili e che
sono costretti a passare la vita
incatenati al letto chiusi in una
camicia di forza rinchiuse a chiave in
una stanza di un manicomio e monis
propone di danneggiare selettivamente i
lobi frontali di questi pazienti in modo
che diventassero quieti
in effetti così era l'intervento si
svolgeva così monis non lo faceva perché
era ammalato avevo un'artrite deformante
che gli impediva di lavorare però aveva
un assistente molto bravo non melme da
lima che lavorava per lui allora almeida
facciamo questo intervento si professore
qui l'osso è molto sottile prendevano un
oggetto acuminato su un telecomando
zac zac il paziente di colpo diventava
tranquillo capite che erano interventi
per gente con stomaci di ferro non c'era
non estesi a generale non c'erano gli
antibiotici
immaginate cosa succedeva se invece di
questo intervento così semplice ne
facevano uno complesso si tagliava la
cute si tra parava al cranio si toglie
un tassello osseo si taglia la meninge
si sposta il cervello e poi magari non
c'è niente operare perché non c'era la
tac non c'era la possibilità di fare
nessun tipo di esame per cui a quel
punto in buon ordine chirurgo richiudeva
cuciva meninge metteva l'orso rimetteva
la cute porgeva le scuse del paziente
che nel frattempo probabilmente era pure
morto perché immaginate le condizioni in
cui si operava ora monizza fronte anche
questo problema e dice ma noi faremo un
grandissimo passo avanti
se invece di operare alla cieca
operassimo sapendo cosa c'è dentro il
cranio hanno appena inventato i raggi
ics che ama suo fido assistente almeida
facciamo una radiografia a questi
pazienti fanno una radiografia e quello
che si vede questo cioè se uno fa una
radiografia una testa
fondamentalmente vede l'osso il cervello
non si vede
allora questo problema in radiologia
viene così affrontato non si vede
utilizziamo un contrasto un contrasto
che possa differenziare una struttura
dall'altra e monis pensa perché devo
mettere un contesto dentro il cranio e
farà un buco lo metto nella carotide e
poi il flusso ematico me lo porterà nel
cranio qualcosa io riuscirò a vedere e
così facendo chiama il fido almeida dice
almeida ci vuole un contrasto si
professore cosa utilizziamo si vuole una
cosa radio papa un metallo ad esempio
qualcosa che fermi raggi e vediamo come
nei rossi professore cosa iniettiamo
iniettiamo il ferro il ferro non va bene
non ce la facciamo mettiamo il piombo
più furbo ma altrettanto poco il
plutonio plutonio non hanno ancora
scoperto però però avevano scoperto il
radio e avevano scoperto anche il torio
velenosissimi ma solubili in acqua per
cui per parlano una soluzione e almeida
aspira in una siringa era inietta nella
carote di un paziente
ok la prima geografia cerebrale moniz
felice al made e felice il paziente
muore immediatamente
non si lasciano certo spaventare da un
cadavere per cui il giorno successivo
riprovano il paziente di nuovo muore e
poi il terzo e muore di nuovo e monet
iscriverà nel suo diario abbiamo fatto
in geografia 12345 malati sono morti
tutti e finalmente il sesto malato non
muore e riescono per la prima volta al
mondo ottenere delle immagini come
quelle che vedete qui e cioè
vermiciattoli neri sono i vasi cerebrali
riempiti di contrasto sono le arterie
che riempiono il cervello e poi il
sangue defluisce nelle vene
non siamo ancora a vedere il cervello
abbiamo un'idea di quello che succede
nella scatola cranica e soprattutto
abbiamo generato una mappa dei vasi ora
questa tecnica viene utilizzata per
molto tempo viene perfezionata i malati
non muoiono quasi mai
ok e per un certo periodo in tutto il
mondo si fanno queste angiografia
cerebrale
fino a che viene sviluppata la tac che
una metodica molto meno invasiva e che
permette di vedere tutto schiacciando
semplicemente un pulsante senza dover
fare del male al paziente per cui questa
metodica rimane così nel limbo poco
utilizzata per per moltissimi anni
a questo punto se ricordate da dove
siamo partiti cioè del sommergibile
atomico che entra nei vasi abbiamo a
bordo rakel welch forse abbiamo a bordo
monis che ci ha disegnato la mappa e
introduciamo il terzo personaggio che è
questo
questo è il papà felice senza occhiali
io ho chiesto a mio figlio perché no la
foto del paziente non si può mettere
disegni un papà felice mio figlio mi
disse papà ferisce con gli occhiali o
papà felice senza occhiali ma felici
senza occhiali per motivi scaramantici
ok e questo è il papà felice senso che
allora il papà felice senza occhiali e
felice perché è natale a questa è una
storia vera e natale
si alza dal letto e di colpo si accascia
di fronte ai due figli alla moglie si
capisce immediatamente che è successa
una cosa gravissima per cui viene
portato di corsa in ospedale in ospedale
facciamo una tac dell'atac sembra
normale non si vede nulla ma il paziente
non si riprende per cui facciamo un
angiografia cerebrale quella di mons
il risultato è questo voi vedete che
questa arteria si suppone vada ad
irrorare al cervello ma non ci va perchè
perchè c'è un coagulo che la occupa e
coagulo ferma il flusso del sangue e il
cervello nutrito la quell'arteria morera
il paziente morera o peggio questa
arteria si che a martelli a basilare
fornisce una struttura cerebrale che il
tronco encefalico il tronco encefalico e
una zona in cui tutti gli impulsi che
della corteccia vanno all'organismo e
dall'organismo vanno alla corteccia la
corteccia e la sede della nostra
coscienza della nostra volontà passano
di lì per cui se io o se un altro ha una
lesione del tronco encefalico e vuole
muovere il braccio sinistro non lo è
perché l'impulso non passa il braccio
destro non lo può muovere le gambe non
le nuove e non parla e non sente nulla e
tutto quello che può fare e muovere gli
occhi perché i neuroni che controllano
gli occhi sono al di sopra di quella
lesione solitamente quadro drammatico
che i neurologi che ha un look di
paziente è chiuso dentro suo stesso
cranio non può fare nient'altro ti
muovere gli occhi ora noi siamo qua
siamo a dieci centimetri da una malattia
tremenda che condannerà questo paziente
ha una vita alla morte se va bene
una vita disperata se va meno bene e non
facciamo nulla allora sono quindici anni
fa non abbiamo le armi per combattere
però a torino e in pochi altri ospedali
al mondo soprattutto in germania
qualcosa proviamo fare tipicamente
iniettiamo lavare tira dei veleni che
sciolgono i coaguli oppure proviamo con
degli strumenti inadatti dei palloni dei
cateteri per le coronarie e qualche
volta abbiamo successo qualche volta
abbiamo degli stati brillanti ma la
maggior parte delle volte le cose vanno
male il paziente muore
nonostante le nostre manovre magari per
colpa delle nostre manovre quadro
sconfortante noi per una decina d'anni
combattiamo contro questa malattia
terribile veramente con le unghie e con
i denti perché non abbiamo altro fino a
che pino che per puro caso
come molte volte succede in medicina
viene sviluppato uno strumentino per
fare tutt'altro che questo strumentino
si rivela assolutamente adatto non a
distruggere il coagulo ma arpionare lo e
portarlo via
come sono andare a pesca mette
quest'anno nel coagulo lo porta via
lo strumentino si chiamerà stent river
perché a metà tra uno stent che una
struttura che serve per tenere aperti
vasi e un retriever che è una cosa che
serve per ritirare le cose e questo
cambia le carte in tavola io ne sento
parlare per la prima volta in un
congresso in francia a gennaio del 2011
e febbraio già provato con il primo
paziente e i risultati sono clamorosi
per cui se oggi arriva il papà felice
in queste condizioni quello che facciamo
e questo lo mettiamo in una sala
angiografica che ci permette di vedere
dove il problema in questo caso è chiusa
la cerebrale media di sinistra e questo
è il nostro nemico lui non muoverà al
braccio destro la gamba destra non
parlare più e noi cosa possiamo fare il
nostro sommergibile nucleare è un
catetere estremamente perfezionato che
parte dalla lingua e dalla mano
dalla carota dove vogliamo purché ci sia
un accesso vascolare e che riesce ad
arrivare nel trombo lo attraversiamo con
la guida metallica poi qui usiamo uno
stand thriller ma una tecnologia diversa
che un grosso tubo con un aspiratore che
arriva che tira che aspira fino a che
ecco qua magia quasi sempre riusciamo ad
aprire il vaso se siamo arrivati
abbastanza intende così siamo arrivati
in una fase in cui il cervello non ha un
danno ancora irreversibile il paziente
se la cava il successo non è il cento
per cento ma se oggi arrivano due papà
felice con una malattia drammatica che
li porterà alla morte o peggio
uno di questi almeno uno se ne torna a
casa a fare esattamente quello che
faceva e per l'altro stiamo lavorando e
per terminare io vi farà rivedere quella
che è la mia astronave con il mio primo
pilota al capitano è sotto
rispettivamente l'equipe e per la che
wells
stiamo lavorando grazie
[Applauso]